you are watching cold fusion TV hey
welcome to another cold fusion video to
go go here obviously this time that's a
little bit different I'm actually
outdoors in melbourne australia on a bit
of a holiday for the holiday season
actually gonna be visiting my sister who
lives here and yeah it's one of but also
wish you guys a season's greetings merry
christmas and a happy new year yes yeah
it's kind of unfiltered and just me
rambling and talking and I don't blog
much I'll take these off I don't vlog
much so this is going to be quite
interesting anyway I just want to say
since I changed the channel name there's
been quite a bit of bro think of doubled
the channel subscribers which is
something that I expected but not to the
extent that it's been so I just want to
say a huge thank you to everyone who's
new year and has been commenting saying
i love the content and they want to see
more which there will be some more of
when i get back obviously i'm thinking
of doing some video of Nikola Tesla so
not the Elon Musk's Tesla but Nikola
Tesla himself and also how big is
Microsoft that's another video that I
want to do and also SpaceX seeing that
they just do a successful landing which
would be the first advance and space
technology in just over 30 years so
that's quite interesting so um yeah I
think that's really what I want to say
so just really it's just more of a merry
christmas and a happy new year and happy
holidays and enjoy your time to relax
and hopefully it's all good so um yeah I
don't know I think that's about it so
thanks for watching guys and I'll stay
in tune for the next video cheers guys
have a good month old Jillian it's me
thinking
you